Speaker 1: At 130 in the morning this morning or
last night or very early this morning, once again,
Donald Trump took not to Twitter, where he is now
unbanned, but to his own platform, truth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth, central.
Speaker 1: And once again,
he started ranting and raving. The level of
instability that these rants are projecting
is really something else. And it seems that with
every bad news cycle, the most recent one being
this entire Kanye White nationalist Nick Fuentes
dinner, Trump goes more and more bonkers on Troth
Central. There is always a feeling of sort of
like, what is he going to become obsessed with
next? And at 130 in the morning, Trump started
by rich frothing his own earlier troth, saying,
quote, Rye No. Karl Rove is a Fox News loser,
a pompous fool with bad political instincts.
In other words, he loses a lot only good at
taking people's money and wasting it. I was
12 to know against him in Senate endorsements.
Not something I'm proud of, but something people,
especially candidates, should know. Trump then
continuing with another one of his fixations,
his endorsement record, also 12 venal in Senate
endorsements against the broken old crow. Mitch
McConnell, who is, by the way, a 6% approval
rating, not exactly great news for the Republican
Party now. I don't know exactly what he's talking
about there. But, you know, Mehmet Oz lost. It
seems that's at least one in Trump's lost column.
It's always very confusing and he's sort of like
the Trump will often limit his endorsement record
to, for example, like endorsements made on even
days of the month when it was sunny. Among that
group, he's four in oh, for example, you know,
it's sort of like with baseball statistics. Trump
continuing this morning, quote, The Manhattan DA's
office has not tried a murder case since 2015,
despite the fact that violent crime in New York
City is at an all time high. Remember, violent
crime is higher in Oklahoma City than it is in New
York City. Trump continuing that six years ago.
And yet after, by the way, it's not six years ago,
it's almost eight. But okay. But maybe math not
his strong suit that six years ago and yet after
years of investigation, millions of dollars spent
and the costly and laborious inspection of almost
10 million pages of documents, we are in the
second week of a fringe benefits case over
an executive's use of a company car, a company
apartment and his grandchildren's education. No
such case has ever been tried before, said
this is Trump furious that his former CFO
is in legal trouble because of things that he
did, quite frankly. Trump then continuing on the
crime spree, as we might call it, saying, quote,
mothers and valleys of victims of violent crime.
And by the way, Mother's is with an apostrophe.
It's just crazy. Mothers in families of victims
of violent crime, which is breaking all capital.
Our records in New York City are furious that
the criminals who killed their loved ones haven't
been given a trial in many years. While millions
of dollars and years of work has been spent on
a ridiculous fringe benefits case, the likes of
which has never been prosecuted before in our
Capital C County's history, I think he means
country. It is a continuation of the greatest
capital W witch hunt of all time. The DA's office
should focus on capital and murders. That's not
lowercase M murders. It's Capital M and violent
crime, not B.S.. And then lastly, and as you might
see, Trump's grammar and spelling degenerating,
the longer this rant continues, quote, Despite
producing tens of thousands of jobs and such
important and lasting structures in New York City,
it is said that I will never be able to get a fair
trial there. Now, it's unclear whether Trump means
it is sad or whether he is saying other people
are saying it's just also unclear. Well, we will
soon see because this case against two companies
is a disgrace that should never have been brought
and has been totally disproven. Even prosecutors
quit the DA's office because they thought it was
unfair. Now that's a lie. Prosecutors quit the
DA's office because they realized we're doing
all this work investigating Trump and he's not
going to be prosecuted. They're not going
to indict him. And our work is for nothing.
That's why they quit. One last line from Trump
here. Such a case has never even been brought
exclamation point before, period. I've never seen
grammar like this before. Justice in America.
This man is unhinged, ladies and gentlemen. I have
not ever seen we've never seen any president do
the things Donald Trump has done. These types
of randomly capitalized mis grammar, stream
of consciousness, sentence fragments and run on
sentences, you see both sentence fragments and run
on sentences. We've never seen anything like this
from any president and the humiliation continues
to grow. I think if we want to find a silver
lining here, the silver lining is because Trump
is posting this stuff to Troth essentially rather
than to Twitter. Fewer people are seeing it.